outtie motorsport division near Ingo
stamp of area is packed today for the
presentation of a new race car which out
he intends to enter in the formula II
World Championship in the coming season
and when formula e is a new race series
for all electric powered formula cars
the first season began in September 2014
last season
team Audi Sport app Schaeffler wrapped
up the overall title
[Music]
Racing hater Matins a board member of
Audis technical development division
says racing is in the company's DNA
electric mobility is important to the
company so of course it's taking part in
the formula e an extremely interesting
platform in the long term developments
in Motorsports
fuel developments in cars for volume
production
[Music]
thirdly mountains explains that the
extreme conditions of racing can teach
the company a lot about the life cycles
of components about how the battery
holds up and about the interplay between
engine transmission and battery so the
racetrack is like an experimental and
fulfills howdy gives 100% support to the
racing team hans-juergen apt founded in
2014
[Music]
the head of Audis motorsport division d2
gus calls out easy throng fp0 for a
fantastic vehicle you don't see much
difference from the outside he says
because the chassis and body are the
same as out ii used in season three but
underneath the carbon fiber chassis
everything is new the company worked on
every system that was open to
development especially the motor
generator unit and the transmission and
then the speedster rolls up howdy is
counting on the abilities of Schaeffler
technologies which produces drive trains
Kepler's Peter Guzman says Schaeffler
and the racing team developed a
completely new powertrain with a one
speed transmission the engine was
completely revised for greater
efficiency
he says Schaeffler is an old hand in its
field but still learned a lot this
season there was enough room to improve
everything including the engines
efficiency and dynamics if it's insta
Nami under the name out eSport app
Schaeffler the team will start in the
new season's first race on December 2nd
in Hong Kong current world champion and
ex Formula One driver lucas di grassi
compares the two racing series
there is a lot of differences between
Formula One and former year what is the
same is the technique to drive this car
fast so to drive any car fast you have
to apply a certain technique and the
difference for people watching is that
formerly only races in cities so all the
races are like Monaco the car is 100%
electric the difference between the cars
are much smaller so the races are much
more competitive dependent it's much
more dependent on the driver as last
year's victor de gauzy is the man the
other drivers aim to beat he views the
coming season soberly these good to say
impossible to say of course we're gonna
fight hard of course you're gonna work
hard but it's impossible to set the
stage
howdy motorsport manager de gas
expresses more optimism
we're the ones they're chasing certainly
he says but how D never enters a racing
category just to have been there but
always to win and this year is no
exception
he thinks OD has a good foundation to
build on and strong driver experience so
it has good chances for victories next
year the company's commitment to the
formula e makes it than German auto
industry's electric mobility pioneer BMW
Mercedes and Porsche won't be far behind